foreign
[Music]
women even know what offside is quote to
eat cardi B's husband we're not dumb
that's Jarren so stupid Kylie would
actually get in it that would have been
actually this is very sexually
orientated podcast but um yeah cardi B's
banging me she is bro she's just sexy
found there was a thing the other day
did you see some performance things she
did the other day I don't think so she
was wearing one head to toe silver latex
thing and she dropped to the floor and
she was whining on the floor
and homeboy was there yeah he was there
shades on staring at that
stare
there
was
oh I couldn't believe it he was and it
actually reminded me of you you know it
was your level of eye contact he was
staring at it I love that yeah yeah he
was all right
yeah
I couldn't have a team I don't care it's
my wife I don't care yeah it is you
can't have a thing wine on a stage
looking at you like that yeah yeah
that's come come here you wanted to hop
the fence come here yeah stop playing
games and come here yeah bang we're
gonna go back to you all right go where
I go it's not evil yeah go on a hair
stylist installed her client's b-day wig
on herself and flew out to Cabo
swag does she replied to her own to be
saying not even Batman could protect her
from from me if this happened
her birthday wig
her hair size just said I'm taking this
this is I'm going to Cabo yeah this is
mine she was trying to find a man out
there yeah this is mine now that's rich
ends this man goes to me for three days
and texted me this morning saying his
charger stopped working but he ordered
one and it came this morning bro you
didn't even care to make up a good lie
certain men just don't care they don't
care yeah like he's he contemplated even
just messaging but I thought if she buys
it then that's Tom's still like it's
still there yeah yeah so let's just see
if she doesn't buy she doesn't buy it
that is what it is I'm not I'm not
really that ass for you yeah oh 100
because a man that ass will lie all
right right you lie right three days
though what was he actually what can you
possibly be doing for three days my
charge just came today yeah he was on
holiday with his misses and his Utes
everyone was in there yeah
you're at a party and a guy whips out
his dick in front of another guy and he
responds hey yo put that meaty
[ __ ] away who are you more mad
at
I think I saw that one put that meaty
[ __ ] away
yo
yo I'll be flabbergasted if one of you
might said that
one Brad whips his tool out and this
man's like yo yo put on me [ __ ]
away bro we playing that
you play that it takes someone's eye out
without it couldn't be a bystand don't
hear that I couldn't
that's that's a level of
conversation I don't want to be around
do you know what will vex me as well is
it will force me to look at it
it will force me to look around and I'm
annoyed yeah
yeah
I say yo all right come on bro what
about me sucker away man look at me
me some slime away bro he doesn't matter
that's funny oh my days so glad my
friends have not left me despite being
the poorest in our group
oh that's actually dread despite being
the poorest being the poorest in our
group before bro we all have I've been
the poorest in our group and I hated it
oh everybody's terrible times bro
terrible terrible types of what soccer
10 years ago turbo types bro
mine wasn't even 10 10 years ago
continues like my mom was like two years
ago
I'm talking about like uni broke though
I was the brokers in uni but it was a
point where like no one remem is the
only one with money in uni
Toby with Toby Toby oh Toby's secret
yeah yeah yeah I remember he had like a
weird like Ash Trail I'm honest on his
uh on his bedside table it just had
notes it just had a clip on it all the
time
infuriated man I remember going into
this bedroom one time obviously smelled
amazing she walked in there super neat
and tidy he's got his Mac the computer
Mac I remember on there and he's just
got a clip on a table and then I'm like
oh bro we're about to head out you're
coming he's like yeah yeah he put his
um his check shirt on yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah his check shirt on and it
had what kick Supras
bro supers yeah I haven't heard that
Brandon so long he used to have those
black and red supers and it just take 20
at an accident it's like 20 hours let's
go I'm like yeah I'm ready and I I I've
never held so much resentment in my life
I was livid bro I was like your life's
so easy so easy bro and you're doing a
real course as well bro at that point I
knew I wasn't gonna be anything
man said I knew I wasn't gonna make it
and I finally I realized my course is a
joke and I'm never gonna make it
[ __ ]
so jarring bro yeah just tell me about
it all yeah yeah oh he had it all he was
just a guy REM had that wholesome 10
bags in his account though
um I'm gonna be brought like a 60-inch
TV one time just cause
because I think Jay message him and said
there's they're doing up cheap TVs
Rumble like two of them oh yeah yes I
just remember now yeah
yeah yeah and I remember Jay's apartment
was doing up
they had they had like 12 books of
Dominoes delivered twice a day do you
remember
everyone was living out but me yeah
you had a shed kitchen so that was a
difference
sorry
that was poor brother you shared your
kitchen with the block yes with the beat
with the rest of the prisoners I shared
it with the rest of the prisoners yours
wasn't yours actually wasn't like a
actual like place it wasn't a living um
habitual at all
it wasn't habitual whatsoever
bro I'm sure it was a refined prison
yeah no someone told me it used to be a
mental hospital my my actual
um wardrobe closed with a curtain
it was there was no door there was no it
was a curtain brother bro the first time
I went to visit I was like right because
I remember when I went to the open day
and we're on an open day and they walked
around the halls and they showed us that
all and they were like this is one of
the [ __ ]
I promise you I'm not living in there
and my mom was so dread she was like
you'll live with her too
I was living because I remember I think
I was one of the last ones I must have
been one of the last ones try and get
accommodation because they said all they
had was Priory which is where I live and
it was either or shared housing I was
like big man I want to stay on don't
scare me like I would have been shared
housing
I'm 16. yeah you're 17. you shed houses
as well bro yeah I remember
see who had shared housing it was
flipping uh what's his name oh that's
actually dread what's his name uh
tall bear black bear anime bro
just see not just no not Jesse
um
come on remember
um danji
yeah yeah dance bro
dance bro dance took me into his
residence one time
scariest thing there's a Chinese murder
in this book zero English yeah there was
another black brother in there who was
about 46 years old uncles yeah and he
took me into his the house was a tip he
took me into the bar I went to use the
toilet one time yeah and he said yeah
don't watch the shower though in it I
went in there there's a bucket and a
sponge in the bathtub
there's a red bucket with a sponge in it
in the bathtub filled with like murky
water
I I run out and said what is that
the man said oh my God
yeah we complaining we've been
complaining I was like no no no no no no
no no you did not get in there and wash
yourself with these buckets daily he
said bro we gotta do it we gotta do we
gotta do bro I don't even think he was
doing a course
[Music]
we didn't see them in between bro he
bailed me one time and said he's in
Africa like doing sugarcane on Saturday
bro he bailed me from Africa one time
just said he's doing up sugarcane or
something at his uncle's ranch or
something like that runs
I'm gonna scream
I'm gonna believe it bro man just said
I've just lost bare weight oh he did I
remember mad
just overheard a guy walk into the
bathroom and say show time to himself
and he sat on the toilet
[Laughter]
show time wow nah yeah his bum moves are
efficient
they're efficient to be fair
it's dump
I nearly text you the other day I took
her [ __ ] the other day
bro I took a good [ __ ] the other day but
it was one of them was my belly was hurt
now I went upstairs
close the door locked it I was there on
the yard closer I locked it put music on
everything shower on
sat down as soon as my cheeks touched
the tip like as soon as they'd like
pressed in and spread out
foreign
[Music]
was Fuller chaos chaos in I was like Wow
and it flushed down not a skid in sight
and I worked out of there and I felt
like a new entire man and I was like
that was the most efficient [ __ ] I've
ever had I was so close to text you like
Fab
the [ __ ] had a strap the [ __ ] I just
shot you wouldn't believe it
wow oh my days that's hilarious yeah
sorry those are the best ones those
definitely are the best ones
oh Jesus bbo farts gotta be hella loud
oh I bet cheeks are clapping absolutely
clapping
um
Jesus
next one uh
Twitter's got the prettiest prostitutes
I've ever seen reply
companion slash escorts but thanks reply
not the hoe pronouns
bro I don't know where someone could get
the goal to say don't you dare call me a
prostitute I'm a companion
shut up
shut up
companion I'm a companion you're not a
companion be quiet
shorts under his pants red flag red flag
red flag he's prepared to stay anywhere
and thus he layers untrue hilarious
entry the amount of times I've stepped
out I've been caught like sleeping in a
yard I didn't want to sleep in yeah yeah
having to sleep in my boxes
I'm only wearing jeans and then straight
to boxes
and in my sleepy time shorts so yeah if
man are just brave enough to be walking
around like that I said it's ready to
stay anyway
you know he's got a wife beer on the
bottom as well it Rags Rags that's too
funny I remember I called one of my
homeboys cried about a guy he said I
could have told you that it was never
gonna be you from the start my soul left
my body for real
damn
speak
shaved coochie has to be eaten that same
day because the next day it's a little
cactus
take the dead skin off your lips yeah
that will exfoliate the [ __ ] out of your
lips bro
[Laughter]
if you if you go against the grain oh
it's slow and you can't get too invested
because otherwise it's red here all from
your nose bottom all the way to your
chin is red
so you have to you have to do a pretty
lips
[Music]